[Music]
I'll get her in here hey Rita alright I
got asked the girl question I understand
you're actually wearing the same dress
that you wore 56 years ago when you won
the Oscar who I want to know how you do
that most of us can't fit the same dress
we let it out a little bit but what we
did was this smarter oh I was just
making it bigger this doesn't need
updating I think this is classic
wonderful that you still a dad you store
and keep it that long and make it
beautiful
hanging in my closet and every once in a
while I go in and stroke and go like now
it's time yeah as one of the very few of
a select group in II got winter we come
back here tonight you look at all these
actors and actresses and all the
multi-dimensional things that they're
doing what would it be like for you
today if you were starting over starting
out well I'd probably work more often I
had a very rough time when I was a
Hollywood girl
and things have changed I think they can
be even better specifically for Latinos
you know I'm curious because you have
been in this business and how have you
enjoyed the times that movement in fact
I think women move forward in this
business that's when you first started I
am so thrilled at the developments in
the last year or so and not only for
that but also actors of color it's just
some enormous the enormous changes oh my
god it's thrilling it's marvelous it's
good it's a good thing
[Music]